Deus Ex and kind divider do's and do  nots decided to use the new Tesla round  make sure your foe is an out of range or  you're going to end up with egg on your  face  engaging a couple of ne'er-do-wells  head-on  remember to reload so you don't get  caught with your trousers down  improvisation is a mark of a good deus  ex payout if you decide to roughhouse  ensure you're properly upgraded do not  dis stand bail out that's the ticket if  you're spotted doing something sinister  by a nosy Jane or John don't forget to  silence them with a quick box around the  ears whose lips sink ships out of  ammunition electromagnetic bullets  aren't effective against human enemies  you know head but they are effective  against surveillance cameras by now  you've probably got quite the mess on  your hands  you know what they say Len leanness is  next to godliness  so always tidy up after yourself and  when in doubt aim for the head